A function, f of x,
is plotted below.
Highlight an interval where
f of x is less than 0.
So f of x-- which is
really being plotted
on the vertical axis
right over here-- x
is the horizontal axis.
f of x being less
than 0 really means
that the graph is
below the x-axis.
So the function is negative in
this interval right over here
and this interval over here.
So I could put this
anywhere right over here,
or I could stick it
anywhere right over here.
Let me stick it right over here.
There we go.
Got it right.
Let's do a couple more.
So the function
is plotted below.
Highlight an interval where
f of x is greater than 0.
So I could do this
area right over here
where the function
is above the x-axis,
or I could do this
area right over here
where the function goes
way above the x-axis.
Well, it even goes off the page.
So let's stick it
right over here.
Let's do one more.
So highlight an interval where
f of x is greater than 0.
Once again, I can do this
region right over here
where the function
is above the x-axis,
or over here where
it's above the x-axis.
I'll do it here just for fun.
There we go.